[Music]
social radicalism is a very broad and
capacious term and the dangerous that it
become quite vague so Richard let me
turn back to you and put to you an
accusation that might be made about
today's parliamentary left in the Labor
Party which is that yes it's much more
ostensibly leftist in its language but
in some ways when you look at the detail
of what Sabre taught leadership are
proposing they keep talking about 1945
as a wonderful moment but it's also
sometimes a kind of economic
conversation that hasn't necessarily
moved on since 1945 in other words
talking about spending very large
amounts on various public goods but not
necessarily looking for genuine radical
change in terms of how the economy can
serve the population the language is
there but the policies don't always seem
to be is that in any way a fair
accusation well I think that we've got
to understand that we're on the back of
neoliberal free-market fundamentalist
economics of the kind that lays
passionately advocates what we've coming
in on the back of 40 years of that in
this country since since 1979 what the
Labour Party manifesto in 2017 proposed
really was moving towards really a kind
of social democratic democratic
socialist Scandinavian model thinking is
a better way possible where people and
the public good are put first rather
than just the pursuit of untrammeled
profits some may call it radical some
may not call it radical I certainly
think well Richard of course Scandinavia
has currently got a Danish Social
Democratic Party that's trying to stop
immigrants coming in Sweden has one of
the first moving far-right movements is
Scandinavia really a place that we want
to aspire to well I'm talking about the
division historically between public
spending between those at the top in
terms of the economic 1% and nopon 1%
and the rest of the population levels of
inequality levels of equality when it
comes to other things of course the
far-right is a threat across across
Europe it's only through
I mean there is a linear link between
what they did in the 80s and what's
happening of course but I think that to
be fair I think Jeremy Corbyn John
McDonald on down Abbott's are a bit more
left-wing than the than the average
Social Democrats in some of these
parties which are facing the problems
which you quite rightly analyze well
thanks for that and if we're bringing
back accusations the parcel is is there
an accusation that it's not 1945 but
1985 year that some of us remember
rather fondly for its music at least
that is still in your mind in other
words that free market libertarian
vision which was a central part of the
intellectual legacy of Thatcherism
doesn't seem to have moved on in third
well the fact is that Britain's economy
was in a dire situation in the 1970s and
it was turned around by a series of
supply-side reforms and which Willman
made our and Orsi old money but what I
would say now is we do face a different
set of challenges but we need to apply
free market mechanisms to solve those
challenges
say for example housing in a Richard
talked about 1945 I think one of the
worst legacies of that government was
the Town and Country Planning Act which
essentially made huge sways of our
country impossible to build on we're now
in a situation where belt well the green
belt in London but we're now in a
situation where people in London who are
renting a paying 50% of their income in
rent
if you look at a city like Tokyo there
has much freer panic planning policies
the rents are much lower people can
afford to live in that city so that to
me is a protectionist top-down planning
policy it isn't a free-market policy
that's do you know I mean if we had a
freer policy if we allowed building
around stations in our Greenbelt which
would be much more environmentally
friendly than putting those houses in
the countryside because people would be
able to commute into work
we could build a million homes for young
people in our greater city say that see
that to me is a radical solution to a
social and economic problem which is
giving people more power over their own
lives and I think the Labour Party
aren't willing to take those kind of
steps we'll get back to live party but
in fact they introduced the tokyo tokyo
is one of the least green cities in the
world
it was also cause flattened by Allied
bombers during that most of the Second
World War which gave more of a kind of
tabula rasa to build up I could
highlight Germany is another country
with extremely good planning policies
they have a zoning system again houses
are more affordable in Germany and home
ownership rates are rising much faster
in Germany we have an incredibly
bureaucratic system that takes ages and
the houses aren't being built so I think
we should learn from these are the
country okay so we'll come back to some
of those measures but I want to get to
to Vince Cable we've mentioned in fact
Richard mentioned the word Social
Democratic
I don't know if to a liberal Democrat
remembering the words SDP from the old
days brings about here a happy free soul
perhaps a slightly nervous one
but there is a reality that what might
have been considered centrist politics I
mean that was always a term that
suggested a kind of safe comfortable
middle now seems to have been heavily
discredited people want radicalism and
if there's one thing that centrism isn't
it's that well to the extent that people
do want radical differences they tend to
be the populist right rather than the
left I would suspect but I just don't
accept that they what I call the social
liberal model which is a mixture of
social democracy and liberal values that
that's in any way discredited or failed
losing elections Vincent that meditation
not at all let me just take the model
that we started discussing a minute ago
which is the Scandinavian country so you
could take Canada I mean there are quite
a few countries in the world which have
a sensible good mixture of things right
their friend surprised economies by and
large they're open to trade and in the
Scandinavian countries to the European
Union they they perform above average
economically they also pay quite a lot
of attention to the redistribution of
income and wealth which is right they
have a healthy welfare state now sure
like all other economies they've come
under a certain amount of stress and you
have some extreme right-wing movements
but but so what I mean you know the
Swedes have a party that gets ten
fifteen percent of the votes on
anti-immigrant prejudice but other than
that the last election we do as we do in
this country as we do in this country
let's not get completely freaked out by
the fact that there is a kind of extreme
right anti-immigrant movement I mean
it's there we've got to deal with it but
it doesn't invalidate the kind of
society that they have created and we
should be trying to strengthen here
which is you know good values getting
getting the private sector working
letting markets operate where it's
appropriate but having a proper
attention to fairness to environment and
so on it's getting
balance right that is critical and
lurching off to ideological extremes is
not I think in any way helpful for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you